[Music]
everyone Eric and Justin from Battle
Damage over the course of season one we
smashed a lot of stuff like a lot of
stuff a lot a lot of stuff without
further ado here's the best of season
one
in today's episode we're gonna see how
well this Nintendo Gameboy Jambox
printer flat-screen TV Apple iPad the
GoPro it's so good
ready it looks a little bent
don't touch that dial TVs don't have
dials anymore what we had preps some
soda cans thinking the potato wouldn't
do much damage
[Music]
which one of these two consoles is the
toughest we're gonna chop the loser in
half with a chainsaw
this is from this that's how strong it
is we figured the best way to determine
the strength of our modern-day boombox
was to tested against the strength of an
original boombox I'm just amazed at how
toughest thing is
boy that was a thrilling inexpensive
couple minutes
sure was Justin sure was let us know
which season 1 episode was your favorite
down there in the comments and remember
we're gonna see you very soon with
season 2 of battle damage
you're paying me back for that stuff
right right